self-recognition that means looking at  the mirror and recognizing ourselves  we don't take it as a huge cognitive  skills right we kind of take it for  granted but do you know monkeys or  gorillas don't have these  self-recognition skill  in order to understand that scientists  have installed mirrors in the jungle and  they monitored the activity of animals  using cctv camera  what they found out was shocking animals  show aggression-like behavior upon  looking at their reflection in the  mirror as if they are somebody else  it turns out that human infants don't  have self-recognition capability until  18th month  so it's kind of a skill that we evolve  gradually in our lifespan  so now the big question is  when in the evolutionary time scale our  ancestor  evolved to recognize themselves  subscribe